the medium is the message you've heard
this phrase before no doubt for a chewy
bit of communications theory it has a
tremendous amount of traction in culture
also if you grew up here in Canada you
may even remember the heritage minute
about Marshall McLuhan's Epiphany it's
obvious the medium is the message so the
medium is the message
in terms of theories few are quite as
well known and yet still to this day
quite so radical that's right even today
51 years after understanding media was
first published the medium is the
message is still a challenging and
radical idea so what does it actually
mean well in McLuhan zone words this is
merely to say that the personal and
social consequences of any medium that
is of any extension of ourselves results
from the new scale that is introduced
into our affairs by each extension of
ourselves the idea is that mediums have
a far greater impact on the fundamental
shape and nature of society than any
message that is delivered through that
medium the electric light reshaped the
way that humans interact with day and
night the train car and airplane
restructured our ideas of what cities
look like and where they can even be
built the radio in television reshaped
the way we structure our time and
reshaped the way that we physically
build and arrange our houses now McLuhan
died in 1980 so he didn't live to see
the Internet as we know it but we can
continue to test his theory against
newer technologies what has had a
greater impact on the way that we as a
society interact with one another
all the content of every YouTube video
ever made or the existence of YouTube
itself
what has had a greater impact on the way
that you interact with the world around
you all the conversations that you have
ever had or your mobile phone now this
isn't to discount the power of content
the power of ideas because obviously the
power of YouTube in the mobile phone is
tied to the volume of the information
that they carry
but McLuhan argues it is only too
typical that the content of any medium
blinds us to the character of the medium
in essence it is an argument of capacity
mediums extending our capability what
makes YouTube powerful is not its
content but its capacity to deliver
content content is potent but it's
comparatively slow ideas take a long
time to sink in to catch on and to
spread but technology will steamroll and
rebuild entire ways of thought over the
course of a decade
if not faster ideas change our
interactions the mediums change the
fundamental scale of those interactions
the cell phone for example completely
reshaped the personal habits and rituals
of social gatherings we have changed the
way that we think about clothing and its
utility to accommodate our phones for a
lot of people the location of power
outlets and cable ports all but dictates
how they arrange the public areas of
their home to draw a comparison to
natural forces ideas are like erosion
powerful and unstoppable but slow
mediums are earthquakes dramatically and
even violently reshaping the landscape
over night when they arrive going back
to this quote the argument to be made
then is that no arguments about ideas
should ever be fully divorced from the
mediums by which those ideas are
delivered and the character of those
mediums because more than just the way
that mediums reshape our physical lives
they reshape the very nature of the
content that they deliver so far I focus
mostly on tangible examples of the way
that we interact with mediums the way
that they directly alter the scale of
our interactions but McLuhan was perhaps
more so interested in how mediums
imprinted themselves into the very
fabric of any content that was delivered
through them and how persistent exposure
to that limitation alters social thought
in the same way that the physical
television alters the arrangement of the
home anyone who has immersed themselves
in Twitter has to adjust to the way that
they think about their use of language
to fit the character limit this has a
direct impact on vocabulary grammar and
the complexity of the communication you
could argue that tumblers unique
expansion of the tag system has
acclimatized users to self visualized as
a series of labels this is because we as
tool users view our tools as extensions
of ourselves the hammer is an extension
of our arm the car an extension of our
body the camera an extension of our eyes
the photograph an extension of our
memory into the internet it is the
pervasive and radical nature of mediums
the ability to get right down into the
root of how we think about ourselves and
our ability to interact with the world
that makes the medium so much more
immediately potent than the content that
is delivered over the medium this is why
social criticism is concerned with
patterns like tropes and stereotypes and
story formula because while we have been
mostly talking about physical devices
and soft
we're platforms is a genre not a type of
medium think about it
genres don't grow on trees and they're
not even universal the three-act
structure is not a physical phenomenon
it's an invention it's a tool in fact if
there's another phrase that encompasses
the Spirit of the medium is the message
it might just be when all you have is a
hammer everything looks like a nail so
what do you think how do the mediums you
use shape the way that you see the world
feel free to let me know in the comments
and until next time go and peace my
children in the name of like share and
subscribe
amen